Issues that arise
at work are often
a reflection of
problems occurring
in the larger society
and the tensions
that we're seeing
out there today.
So today, unfortunately
all around the world,
we're seeing conflicts,
sometimes verbal attacks,
sometimes physical attacks.
Maybe it's refugees from Syria
or other war-torn countries
trying to find a place
to live in Europe.
Maybe it's a tax on immigrants.
Maybe in the United
States, now it
seems to be attacks on
religious groups, Muslims.
Sometimes now we're seeing
racial conflicts rise again.
So we thought it would
be useful in this course
to have a conversation about
how these conflicts then affect
the workplace, and
what we've learned
over the years about how to
address them effectively.
And we're fortunate to have
a world-class expert here
to draw on.
I'm talking today with
Professor Mary Rowe, a friend
and colleague here
in the Sloan School.
Mary has been the ombudsperson
for MIT for 40 years,
and she's now taking
time to reflect
on the lessons she learned
from that experience
and its implications for
how we can move forward.
So Mary, thank you
for joining us today.
My pleasure.
So why don't we start
right at the beginning.
What is an ombudsman or a
ombudsperson or ombuds--
whatever the
appropriate term is?
And what does a person
in that role do?
An organizational ombud--
and there's lots of us
now around the world.
I'm guessing that there
are probably about 1,000
of us in corporations
and government agencies
and academic institutions
around the world.
It's a neutral.
Many people know
what a mediator does.
And if you can imagine
an internal mediator who
works on any kind of problem
that comes to him or her,
that begins the picture.
We're independent of all
line and staff offices.
By standards of
practice, we report
to the chief executive officer
or above him or her to a board.
We're informal.
We don't have any
management power.
We can't fix anything.
And we are confidential.
That's perhaps the most
important thing for your talk
today.
We keep no case records
for our organizations.
Anybody can-- we're called
a zero-barrier office.
We should establish
an office where
there are no barriers
at all to being
able to come to talk with us.
Well, that's a
good introduction.
And I know you have emphasized
the need for multiple tools
to fit into what you have called
a conflict management system.
Could you describe what
some of these tools
are that are needed for people
in your role to be effective?
Well, people in my role
need various kinds of tools.
We think of a sense of humor,
integrity, intelligence,
caring.
Especially important,
especially because of what
you were saying before about
the origins of conflict,
we think of ombudsmen
as needing to have a lot
of cross-cultural experience.
And indeed, my profession is
one of the best integrated
professions in the world
by race and by gender.
I'm very proud of that.
But I think you're
also thinking about
what needs to be in an
organizational system
to deal with conflicts in the
workplace and with students,
and so on.
Is that right?
That's right.
Some of the tools and the
options that I know you
consider important.
Lots of people who think
about this question
think first about, do we have
a formal grievance procedure?
And that, of course, is
a very important question
for the most grievous
problems and the ones that
need a management decision.
But most problems will
yield to people thinking
about their own
interests and those
of others at what
people-- at what
organizations think of as
the lowest possible level.
So at the lowest
possible level, we
want conflict settled
onsite, if possible.
And at the last
end of the line, we
would think of formal
grievance procedures,
and then there are lots and
lots of steps in between.
And some of those
steps really empower
individuals to deal with
conflicts more effectively.
And I know you have spent
a lot of time working
to help individuals
figure out what
options are best for her or
for him in addressing these.
What would some of
those options be?
When people think
about ombudsmen
or when they think about
taking an ombuds job,
they often think about
conflict management
as dispute resolution.
A given dispute comes, and
they step in with a magic wand
and fix it.
And point of fact, very
good ombuds and those
in place for a long time
generally spend more than half
their time helping
people help themselves
to learn how to
deal with conflicts
and even to prevent them.
And that's true for both
individuals and for groups.
So helping people
help themselves,
listening to people
talk about their issues,
getting them to
articulate their concerns,
having more formal consultation
in organizations and forums
for affinity groups, and maybe
sometimes counsels of people
coming together.
These are all part of
a larger system that I
know you have emphasized.
Do we have room for me
to tell a quick story?
Sure.
You know, I'm just looking
back at my old papers.
In the 1970s and '80s,
I was young economist,
and I came from
the outside to MIT.
I was overwhelmed
by having 100 people
come to me in my first
week, no two of them
with the same issue.
And I didn't have any
expertise on any one of them.
But what I did do
with the total backing
of my boss, the president,
was to get any two people who
had the same issue together with
each other to try to figure out
what kind of systems change
might help deal with that issue
or even prevent it.
Now here's what I
just discovered.
In those 17 years, there were
at least 60 women's groups alone
and many minority groups--
I haven't yet got a
perfect count of them--
and many cohort groups like
engineering assistance,
who got themselves together
to, as affinity groups,
if you will, to
propose solutions.
So that's just one example
of what you're seeing.
Well, I like the emphasis
that you put on systems,
that these different
options need to be there,
because people have
different preferences for how
they approach these issues.
And you have been very
skillful in helping
people find something
they're comfortable with.
And I think that's really
critical to making these work.
But you've also developed this
concept of micro-inequities.
And we've heard about
microaggressions,
but you've kind of
turned that into ways
to deal with these
in positive ways.
What are micro-inequities?
And then we can talk about
how to perhaps deal with them.
But this is something
that I think
is particularly unique
to your own work.
I was very honored
before and just
after I came to MIT to have as
a mentor Dr. Chester Pierce.
Many people nowadays remember
him, a very prominent
psychiatrist and a neurologist.
Chet Pierce came up with
the idea of microaggressions
in 1970, talking about racism
and talking about hostile acts.
And he was simply
extraordinary in helping
to develop that idea.
When I came to MIT, very
grateful to him for what
I had learned about
microaggressions.
I found microaggressions,
and of course we still do.
But I found a great
deal more besides.
There are hostile acts,
as all of us know,
and there's a great deal
of small acts of racism,
and religious intolerance,
and sexism, and so on.
In addition, I discovered a
lot of complaints and concerns
that appeared to me to arise
out of unconscious bias.
That is to say, not
available to the person who
is behaving in a way that
he or she might even regret.
And in 1973, I found
myself doing this.
And in fact, my kids were simply
delighted to catch me doing it.
So unconscious bias
was a big deal for me,
and then I began to discover
these little aggressions
or inequities, if
you will, that seemed
to arise just out of negligence.
I knew better, but
I just blew it.
And then finally, there
was a large clump of them.
Again, problems that
were problems for me
myself that arose out of what
I will call innocent ignorance.
A lot of ignorance
is not innocent.
But I lived in West
Africa just before I came.
I inadvertently served
food with my left hand
to Muslim colleagues.
I made the mistake of
showing the bottom of my foot
in a meeting, and in a very
polite Muslim meeting in West
Africa.
I learned that it's
very easy to be
very offensive on
the basis of problems
that one just didn't know exist.
So with great respect and
with Chet Pierce's blessing,
I extended the idea
of microaggressions
to include these other
huge groups of problems.
Sexism as well as racism,
and just plain bullying,
as well as either.
Yeah.
So these micro-inequities often
are happening even though we're
not always aware of them.
But you've tried to make
this a more positive approach
to addressing these issues.
And you call them
micro-affirmations.
Tell us what you mean by that.
Give us some examples
of how one can deal
with these micro-inequities.
Again, it was partly in
an effort to make sure
that I was myself not
committing, if you will,
micro-inequities right and left.
And here was my problem, Tom.
I thought to myself, if
some of these problems
come from unconscious
bias, and there's
no way we can be aware,
without a lot of work at least,
to be aware of our
own unconscious bias,
what hope is there for me?
So I read and I thought.
Psychology gave me
a clue, which is
that if one always behaves
in a respectful way
and seeks out that
which can be affirmed
in everything around
one in one's work group,
always genuinely, of course,
things that really are going
well, if one's
whole life is spent
in genuine affirmation of
other people's excellence
and in respectful
behavior, you can block
your own unconscious bias.
So my first thought
about affirmations
was really in an effort to
do something about myself.
It turns out that
micro-affirmations
have a whole lot of other
good aspects to them.
They make people happy.
The work of the
negotiation project
on core emotional concerns shows
that approval and affirmation
are two of the most important
core emotional concerns
that every single person
has all over the world.
And if I lived my life
in micro-affirmations,
I am by definition reaching out
to the core emotional wishes
of everybody I'm
interacting with.
And those are just two of the--
you'll have a chart--
those are just two of the
ways that micro-affirmations
can be helpful.
So by affirming good
behavior and recognizing it
and providing psychological
rewards and role
modeling in your own
behavior, you often
make it contagious for
others in one's work group,
it sounds like.
This is the way
in which you show
by creating an
environment of support
that we aren't going
to tolerate inequities.
And you change attitudes
by changing behavior.
Exactly so.
We've known for a long time
that attitudes affect behavior.
More recently, we've
learned that our behavior
can change our own attitudes.
That's a big deal.
I think that's a
really important point.
And it has good
psychological research bases,
but it also just makes
good common sense
that we learn from each others'
experience at young ages
and in our workplaces as well.
So that's very helpful.
But I want to turn
to another idea
that you have
championed and used
so effectively over the
years, and that's something
that we call bystanders,
that you call bystanders
in particular.
And we're all bystanders, and
we see bad things happening
in our workplace, in our--
wherever we are in society.
And we come home, and the next
morning in the shower we say,
gee, I wish I would
have done something.
Tell us what you've
learned about how
to be an effective
intervener when one sees them
in a bystander role
and sees something bad
happening at the workplace.
Bystanders have a bad
name all over the world.
And in fact, the
term bystander effect
is often used to
mean somebody who
stands by and lets racism or
unsafe behavior or something
terrible happen.
When I began looking
at all of this,
I began looking at it from the
point of view of an ombudsman
because where very bad
things or very good things
happen in the workplace, usually
there's no supervisor there,
but there are peers
and bystanders.
So I thought, here
is enormous leverage
either in getting wonderful
recognition for good behavior
or in getting unacceptable
behavior stopped.
So I began to study it.
First of all, the bystander
effect, the so-called bystander
effect, it was studied
in a very narrow context.
And even in that context,
it isn't always the case.
But so what do
bystanders actually
do when they see something
unacceptable or scary?
It could be a safety problem.
It could be a mistake.
It could be an error.
Or it could be really
unacceptable personal behavior
or group behavior.
Most bystanders
funnel very quickly
through a great many options.
And this is really the point
of where I'm coming to.
Those who run organizations
usually think of bystanders
as either doing nothing
or reporting immediately
to the authorities.
That meaning, responsible
bystanders do nothing,
or I guess they
don't do anything.
And if they're responsible,
they only report to authorities.
In real life, bystanders do
all kinds of other things,
and I began to study that for
my last 15 years as an ombud.
I collected everything that
people told me in my office
that they had
considered when they
saw either wonderful behavior
or terrible behavior.
What options did they consider?
And it's very rare
that they considered
going to authorities, and
mostly they did want to act.
So they came up with lots
of other possible options
for how to get something fixed
or prevented or remediated.
What would some of
those options be?
Obviously, it means one
has to sort of disrupt
the behavior in real
time in some way,
or change the behavior.
So can you give us an example
or examples of actions
that you've seen people take
that have been effective?
Well, again, your
question is a perfect one.
Because in real life, people
often don't act on the spot,
in the moment.
They think about it.
And they might act on
the spot in the moment,
but they think about it,
and they worry about it.
This is the responsible
bystander again.
Some of the options
they choose would
be to go home and talk
with trusted family,
or in the workplace with
trusted friends and peers.
Or if they have a boss
that they really trust,
they might ask about
it hypothetically.
Like, boss, if
something like this
were to happen, what
would you think about it?
What could the organization
do with a problem like this?
Other possibilities
would be that they
would get a generic
approach to deal with it.
If it's an organization
that does a lot of training,
maybe a training program that
can be brought in in which
we just happen to mention
this kind of behavior.
Sometimes a person will act, but
only together with a coworker.
So Tom, I'm thinking now, who
do I trust in my workplace?
Who would come with me
to talk with a boss?
I wonder if I
could write a note.
I wonder if there's
any manager who cares
about this kind of behavior.
Sometimes it might be
[? audit,  ?] for example,
or it might be the EEO office.
Maybe I could write
a note and have
them think about
this kind of problem
in my section of
my organization.
So there are lots and
lots of different options
that responsible
bystanders will choose.
Well, I like the
way in which you
describe how you talk with
people to generate options
like this.
Maybe really skilled
people or people
who have a mindset can
interrupt behavior on the spot,
but often it's reflecting,
OK, what could I do tomorrow?
What could I do
today in retrospect?
And it's finding those different
approaches that's so key.
So if I'm hearing you right,
Mary, what you're saying
is organizations
really need to have
respected, independent neutrals
who are supported by a conflict
management system
with multiple options,
because people have different
approaches to dealing
with workplace problems, and
they need different outlets
for addressing them.
And then secondly, they need
to have tools and training
so that not only are
the professionals
good at addressing these
issues, but so are managers,
and so are frontline
employees, so that they
can be ready to put
these tools to use,
and they have to
trust these tools.
And then third, you
have to create a culture
in the organization that
empowers people to take action
to help themselves and
help others safely.
So do you have
any final thoughts
on how we can put all
these tools to use
to deal with the modern problems
that we see in workplaces
today?
I have two final thoughts.
One is if you who
are listening to this
is just an individual by
yourself, and maybe even young
and you think you have
no power, you always
have options, just one
person, to make things
better wherever you are.
If you who are listening
to this are a manager,
think about a systems approach
within your organization
to help other people to help
you with a strategic plan
to build an affirming workplace.
Well, Mary, thank you very much.
Thank you for all that you do
and all that you have done,
not only here in
our organization,
but around the
world to help others
build these kinds of
systems and capacity.
And so there's lots
of issues to address,
and we just have
to stick with it.
So thank you very much.
Thank you, Tom.